but we begin with this Fox News Alert
sources have now confirmed to Fox that
the doj special counsel investigating
former president Trump's handling of
classified documents has now convened a
second grand jury this one not in D.C
but in South Florida that would be the
same district where Mar-A-Lago is and
based on what we are hearing the special
counsel is now poised to wrap up that
probe and there are many reports that
charges could in fact be imminent at the
very same time we are learning that an
indictment against Hunter Biden could
also be forthcoming but don't expect
expect Hunter's charges to implicate the
big guy this will be all about Optics
not about justice as president Trump
truthed out earlier today they'll hit
Hunter with something small to make
their strike on me look fair I would
expect that to probably in all
likelihood happen now make no mistake
it's all one big political game for
Biden's doj and of course the
allegations against Hunter are
significant but only because they
implicate his father the president then
vice president and a possible bribery
scheme money in exchange for specific
acts for example I don't think most
people really care about these sordid
private life of a notorious loser former
crackhead prostitute loving Hunter Biden
we do care about public corruption and
there is a mountain of evidence that is
emerging that Joe Biden could be corrupt
to the core and has been for some time
now exhibit A's Hunter Biden's very own
laptop that has been in the FBI's
possession as we've been telling you
since 2019 December of 2019 John Solomon
says the contents of that laptop were
verified and authenticated by the FBI a
short time later and those contents are
damning a text showing Hunter
complaining about having a fork over
half of his earnings to his father to
Pops one email revealing Hunter even
paid his father's bills an upkeep on his
Mansion another email discussing a
potential 10 payout to quote the big guy
we were told who the big guy was in that
regards a business deal in China but
according to job he's never ever not one
single time ever discussed his son's
foreign business dealings ever listen
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
well Joe Biden was lying then and he's
lying now and he lied over and over
again Biden personally met with at least
14 of hunters businesses Associates he's
pictured here with Hunter's Kazakh
business partners uh and here he is by
the way with Hunter's Mexican Associates
and here he is on the golf course with
Devin Archer who served on the board of
barisma with his son Hunter and during
Joe's time as vice president while
Hunter Biden's business associates they
visited the White House over 80 times
the very same time period that a
confidential human source told the FBI
that Biden was taking foreign bribes in
exchange for specific policy decisions
and actions this was not just any
confidential human Source by the way
according to a brand new report out
tonight from John Solomon this Source
was so trusted and so valuable that the
FBI previously paid the source uh two
hundred thousand dollars for his
information take a look The Source who
formed the basis of the 1023
is a long-serving FBI source
Source reportedly received numerous
validations from the FBI
The Source reportedly operated even
during the Obama Administration the FBI
Source in the 1023 has been paid at
least two hundred thousand
dollars by the FBI since the source was
opened and operational
now it seems like that Source was highly
valued now according to the allegations
this purported foreign bribery scheme
took place in Ukraine where Hunter Biden
was breaking in a fortune on the board
of barismo that's the Ukrainian oil and
gas giant and of course he admitted on
Good Morning America he had no
experience in energy at all no
experience in Ukraine remember Biden
withheld the billion U.S taxpayer
dollars and said you have six hours to
fire that prosecutor and Son of a bee
they did it that's the same prosecutor
we now know was investigating barisma
and his own son for corruption now
here's chairman Comer with much more
take a look this uh form 1023 involves a
business person from Ukraine who
allegedly sent a bribe a substantial
bribe to then Vice President Joe Biden
now just to recap we have allegations of
a bribery scandal from a confidential
human source that the FBI apparently
believed is credible we have emails and
texts from Hunter Biden's laptop we now
have bank records we have all the
suspicious activity reports and a paper
trail showing the transfer of foreign
money through shell corporations in
other words they were llc's they weren't
designed to make any business profitable
but anyway those LLCs were used to
funnel money to various members of the
Biden family according to Comer
including the big guy himself and we
also have photographs of Biden meeting
with his son's Farm business associates
and we have Joe Biden on tape lying
about the meetings so the question for
you Christopher Ray you're the FBI
director you swore you'd clean up this
you know once the premier law
enforcement agency in the world no
longer sadly uh for you and for you know
are you blind and Merrick Garland you're
okay with all this this doesn't you know
in any way raise any questions in your
mind you condone this Behavior at best
hunter was likely lobbying his father on
behalf of foreign clients at worst he
was collecting bribes in exchange for
specific policy decisions as alleged by
the FBI Source now but did Hunter even
register as a foreign agent will he be
charged with any federal violations like
say Paul manafort or will he skate by
with a simple gun charge a couple of tax
charges just to keep a degree of
separation between Hunter and Joe and
act like they are fair as they go
forward with any plans they might have
to indict Donald Trump uh which by the
way I think we all know the answer Joe
Biden will be protected at all costs
especially by this FBI and this doj all
while his political opponent Donald
Trump will be persecuted around every
turn hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox whose YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else